Salut ! Aujourd'hui je vous donne la réponse de l'énigme d'hier.
Vous allez me détester je pense quand vous allez entendre la réponse, si vous ne l'aviez pas trouvé.
Si vous n'avez pas regardé l'énigme d'hier, foncez la regarder tout de suite, avant de regarder la réponse, qui est maintenant.
La réponse à "Combien de personnes vont à la plage ?", est 1 seule personne.
Et oui, car la personne qui va à la plage, rencontre les autres qui en reviennent, puisqu'il les croisent.
En fait tout est dans le mot "croiser".
Comme il croise toutes les personnes que j'ai cité, ça veut dire que celles-là ne vont pas à la plage, mais qu'ils en reviennent.
Il est donc tout seul à aller à la plage.
Ne me détestez pas ! Ne me brulez pas !
Un énigme c'est fait aussi pour ça. Pour avoir un angle de vue différent et peser le poids de chaque mot.
Et puis je suis sûr de toute manière, qu'il y en avait pleins qui avaient trouvé la solution.
Et si ce n'est pas le cas, vous trouverez celle d'aujourd'hui.
C'est parti pour l'énigme du jour !
Enigme numéro 6 !
J'ai beaucoup trop d'énergie quand je vous annonce les numéros des énigmes...
Et en même temps je me sens comme lui. Vous êtes peut-être en train de profiter du soleil, et moi je suis dans mon bocal en train de faire toutes ces vidéos !
Mais si vous avez suivi, vous savez que je triche. Je suis en ce moment en vacances,  et j'ai tourné ces vidéos avant l'été au YouTube Space.
Une énigme qui est peut-être connue, en tout cas c'est le sentiment que j'ai parce que je la connais depuis que je suis tout petit.
Mais je vous la soumet aujourd'hui.
C'est l'histoire d'un chasseur.
Un chasseur qui cherche à tuer un ours.
C'est pas bien !
Je suis contre ça !
Mais heureusement ce n'est que dans l'énigme !
Notre chasseur repère un ours.
Et il veut le prendre par surprise. Il veut le contourner.
Malin notre chasseur !
Notre chasseur part 10 km vers le Sud.
Donc il prend sa boussole, et il va 10 km vers le Sud.
Donc vers le bas.
Ensuite il fait 10 km vers l'Est.
Toujours avec sa boussole, il fait 10 km à pieds vers l'Est.
Puis il fait 10 km vers le Nord.
Toujours avec sa boussole, il fait 10 km vers le Nord.
Et il se dit "je n'ai plus qu'à changer une seule fois de direction et je suis bon, je l'aurai contourné".
Mais une fois qu'il a fini à marcher ces 10 km vers le Nord, il retombe nez à nez avec l'ours.
L'ours qui n'a pas bougé de son emplacement.
C'est-à-dire que durant tout le trajet du chasseur, l'ours n'a pas bougé d'un centimètre.
Ma question est:
De quelle couleur est l'ours ?
Vous ne l'attendiez pas celle-là, hein ?!
Alors ce n'est pas une blague, c'est vraiment la question de l'énigme.
De quelle couleur est l'ours ?
Il y a une réponse très logique pour connaître la couleur de l'ours, et surtout pour savoir expliquer pourquoi l'ours a cette couleur là.
Vous avez jusque demain pour réfléchir, parce que demain je vous donnerai la réponse.
Si vous avez la réponse, ne la mettez pas dans les commentaires, laissez les autres chercher, c'est beaucoup mieux !
Par contre dès que vous avez trouvé, ou que vous connaissiez déjà l'énigme, mettez un pouce en l'air, ce qui permettra de voir le nombre de personnes qui auront résolu ce mystère de l'ours
de je ne sais pas quelle couleur...
Profitez du soleil ! Profitez de l'été !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaine avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !